[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette journée est extrêmement important
c'est vraiment une étape clé dans un
projet qui dure déjà maintenant depuis
quatre cinq ans nos ambitions sur ce
territoire sont dire est très importante
sa structure est le choix le désir de
venir s'associer aux entreprises
existantes à celles à venir
les universités les grandes écoles sur
le plateau de saclay parce que sa
rentrée complètement en synergie avec le
projet de recherche servier qui était de
rassembler nos équipes sur un même site
et de continuer à promouvoir la
recherche ouverte avec évidemment les
partenaires locaux
et puis après bien au delà mondiaux on a
aussi construit ce site de façon à
pouvoir accueillir beaucoup de
chercheurs et de collaborateurs de
l'extérieur le partenaire de l'extérieur
et enfin je dirais la cerise sur le
gâteau c'est la partie hôtel à projet de
ce
de ce projet instituts de recherche
servier paris saclay qui va permettre à
de jeunes pousses des start up des
biotech de nous rejoindre à l'intérieur
du cluster servier qui lui-même est à
l'intérieur du kloster paris saclay
[Musique]
c'est vraiment le projet de jean michel
wilmotte qui a le mieux capturer les
intuitions les envies de nos chercheurs
on veut s'inscrire complètement sur
l'histoire de ce plateau de saclay qui a
d'abord une histoire agricole de
fertilisation et comme l'a expliqué
notre président plus tôt ce matin
c'est après la fertilisation des sols
c'est la fertilisation de la
l'innovation et on veut que ce projet
s'inscrit aussi dans cette dimension là
donc c'est extrêmement éco responsable
on veut une empreinte co2 minimum
éventuellement même positive pour pour
ce site avec énormément de
végétalisation des surfaces d énorme
jardin entre les bâtiments un jardin
central qui est propice à la réflexion à
les changes et à l'ouverture d'esprit
entre le printemps et l'automne 2022 on
aura intégré toutes vos équipes et elles
seront pleinement fonctionnel sur ce
merveilleux kloster
[Musique]